Federal officials have
been working around the clock
to try to find some resolution
in the wake of the collapse
of Silicon Valley Bank.
And tonight,
the Treasury
Department, FDIC and Federal Reserve,
all releasing a statement
saying that all depositors
with money at Silicon
Valley Bank will be made whole.
That includes the depositors
who previously
they're depositors only up to $250,000
had been insured.
Additionally,
they also announced that a second bank
signature bank has also been closed.
I want to read you
a bit of this statement
which said that after consultation
with the FDIC, the Federal Reserve
and also President Biden
quote, Secretary Yellen
approved actions enabling the FDIC
to complete its resolution
of Silicon Valley Bank,
Santa Clara,
California, in a manner
that fully protects all depositors.
Depositors will have access
to all of their money
starting Monday, March 13th.
No losses
associated with the resolution
of Silicon Valley Bank
will be borne by the taxpayer.
The statement goes on to say,
They are extending the same protections
to those depositors with money,
a signature bank,
which is based in New York.
And additionally,
they said that
shareholders and certain unsecured
debt holders will not be protected,
nor will be senior management
at this company.
This comes
as they have
really been trying
to seek this resolution to the issues
that depositors are facing in the wake
of the closing
of Silicon Valley
Bank, about 90% of depositors
had money over $250,000,
which was the previous limit
that the FDIC insured,
leaving many questioning
what exactly they would do
and how payroll would be met
heading into this week.
Now we are still waiting to get
some more specifics
from the Treasury Department
and other regulators here in Washington.
But it comes at a time,
as they have been working
very closely on this matter,
trying to prevent any further
jitters that it could
cause for the banking system and the U.S.
economy.
I will note in this statement,
they also try to stress the resilience
of the banking system in this moment,
in part based on those protections
that were regulations
that were put in place
after the financial crisis in 2008.
All right. Our right.
Thank you very much.
And CNN
economics and political commentator
Catherine Rampell is back with us.
Catherine, your reaction
to this statement?
I'm just looking at what the
this joint statement
that came out from the treasury secretary
the Federal Reserve chair
and the FDIC chairman.
It also mentions,
as Arlette was saying, signature bank
and so on
at the close of business on Friday.
We had heard about Silicon Valley Bank.
Now we're hearing about a second bank
that is obviously going to
cause some concern
that some of this is spreading
and that this is becoming a larger issue.
Yes, there were a number of banks
that saw their stock prices
tank on Friday
as a result of concerns
about Silicon Valley Bank.
People were worried, well,
that happen there.
Maybe it can happen here as well.
I've also heard lots of reports
about people
pulling their money
out of a range of other
kind of comparable,
mid-sized, mid
mid to large sized regional banks
that didn't necessarily
exhibit any signs of stress prior
to all of this.
It's this sort of contagion,
this financial panic contagion.
And which is why
precisely why the administration
and the federal Reserve
were keen
on making sure that they stopped
the panic here
before it spread
to other financial institutions.
And I think that's
what they're hoping happened here,
that the depositors
at Silicon Valley
Bank and its signature
bank are being told
that they will be made whole.
There apparently wasn't a buyer
for Silicon Valley Bank,
despite the request for bids,
or at least nothing
that's been announced so far.
But the FDIC, in conjunction
with the Federal Reserve
and the Treasury Secretary,
apparently determined that there would be
what's called a systemic risk exception
and that they would make sure
that that the government essentially
would make sure
that those who had deposits at Silicon
Valley Bank would be made whole.
Normally, again,
the FDIC only insures
deposits up to $250,000.
That was not the case
of many of the deposits.
Many of the accounts
at this bank exceeded
far exceeded that level.
So the idea here is to calm that concern,
calm the concern of any depositors
at comparable banks
so that they don't
that that sort of panic
doesn't feed on itself.
That's the goal here.
Right.
And Catherine, just a quick follow up.
We're looking at
what it looks like
we're going to be seeing
on Wall Street tomorrow.
Morning, the Dow futures,
NASDAQ futures, S&P. 500 futures.
They don't appear
to be spooked at this point,
but we know that there are jitters
and concerns that some of this may.
I mean,
I think Maxine Waters
was using the word contagion earlier
when we were talking to her
earlier on in this hour,
that this may lead to more fear
and loathing on Wall Street.
But at this point,
we're not really seeing that
at this point.
Well, I think the hope was that
in some sense,
the feds would step
in, whether that meant
finding another buyer, whether that meant
relaxing access
to the Fed's lending window,
which they also did,
or whether that meant stepping in
and essentially
having the government
guarantee that all of the deposits
at these
couple of banks
would be fully accessible tomorrow
in their entirety,
not just weeks from now.
Up to $200,000
or after all of this was sorted out, etc.
That's why there was a lot of concern.
So now that the government has stepped in
and tried to provide a resolution
that may be calming
some of those jitters,
I don't know if it'll be sufficient
because they've only announced it
for these two banks.
The question is
how do investors, how do depositors
extrapolate to other banks?
Do they say, aha,
if the
if the FDIC and Treasury and the Fed
were willing to
stop the
panic, stop the
bleeding at this one bank,
will they do it at my bank as well?
And we don't know yet
how that will be interpreted.
I'm sure I'll be looking, as others
will, at markets tomorrow
and at behavior
at these financial institutions tomorrow.
Absolutely.
If folks are lining up at the bank,
that that might be a sign
of where things might be heading.
Our Catherine Rampell, thank you so much.
We appreciate it.